la reunión de ministros de energía que
se ha producido en Praga ya ha terminado
Y aunque no se esperaban resultados
concretos Sobre qué es lo que se puede
hacer para bajar los precios de la
energía Así que ha ayudado a acercarse a
este punto qué es lo que se puede hacer
para poder abaratar los precios de la
electricidad la gran mayoría de países
está a favor de que se deben abaratar
estos precios pero aún no se han puesto
de acuerdo en cómo se puede hacer aún
así la gran mayoría sí que accede por
ejemplo hacer una compra conjunta de gas
entre todos los países Y así pueda
costar mucho menos el gas el que se
importa en este sentido la comisión
europea va a anunciar nuevas medidas ya
la semana que viene Como por ejemplo
esta compra conjunta de gas pero también
una de las mayores discusiones donde hay
menos consenso es en la de poner un
límite en el precio del gas los líderes
tendrían que abordarlo la semana que
viene en una reunión extraordinaria aquí
en Bruselas